foreign
hey guys this is alt shift X and I'm
talking about Dune with a special guest
welcome Quinn from Quinn's ideas thanks
for coming man
no problem it's a pleasure to be here
I'm excited to talk about doing it's
been a while since we've had a chat
about Dune and looking forward to the
fun today yeah yeah me too we spoke a
year ago
um after the release of June fought one
and now we have all this juicy Dune part
2 stuff to talk about two trailers uh
two whole trailers which have some like
interesting surprising stuff in them
that I wasn't expecting like some of
that some of that euroland stuff
um surprised me what what surprised
getting an expanded role
um
what surprised me I don't know if I was
like totally surprised more than I was
just like oh it's cool to see that it
was cool to see uh what you have up on
the screen right now like the nuke thing
yeah that wasn't I wasn't expecting in
the show that in the trailer at all so
that's that was an interesting thing to
see because that's kind of like a oh
crap when that's happening in the book a
little bit yeah yeah there's a lot of
stuff in the trailers where I was like
oh wow like they're showing that that's
kind of spoilery
um I think they're probably banking on
people not really knowing what it is
because I don't think that every I think
they're probably banking on people not
having read the books really
yeah yeah because that's the thing like
because we've read the books we
recognize what things are and how
significant they are but people who
haven't read the books it's just like oh
it's just an explosion like I don't know
what that just means so it's fine
um the the previous videos I did were
like no spoiler videos but I want to say
that this is a spoilery live stream so
we will talk about what happens at the
end uh so you you have been warned uh
which means that we get to talk about
some of the implications of some of
what's going on in these trailers and
what they might mean
um I mean I mean if we want to start
with the explosions I mean I was
surprised by how many there are
um like like I guess this huge explosion
on screen right now is the destruction
of The Shield wall which is how Paul
lets all the sand worms in to attack the
emperor
um it seems to be no I I did hear before
the release of the trailer I heard the
rumor that the second part was gonna
have a lot more action be a lot more
heavy on the action and that seems be
what the trailer especially the second
one they released definitely shows
yeah yeah vilnov said in some interview
that like yeah this is an epic
action-packed war movie which I I wonder
if that's like uh if like the studio was
saying that we need to make this more
exciting because like one of the most
common criticisms I heard of June part
one was that it was boring for some
people like it felt very slow and
contemplative and so I wonder if the
studio was like well focus group testing
says we need more explosions because
people keep falling asleep in this movie
we need more action
I wonder if that's what that would do
yeah
I think maybe that was a part of it but
I also feel like it might have always
been the intention because I think Frank
Herbert even described Doom as having
like what he called a colloidal Rhythm I
think that was just a term that he kind
of invented
some Rhythm yeah or something like that
I must have said it wrong yeah it's I
guess it's like it increases gradually
as the story goes on and it kind of like
gets to this Crescendo so I feel like
maybe that was always a part of
villanov's plan and then
um
um that's why the the first movie is a
little slower because it's like this is
just the beginning of the film because I
think Villeneuve really sees it as one
movie I don't think he really sees it as
Doom part one Doom part two yeah yeah
he's emphasized in interviews that it's
it's not a sequel It's a continuation
it's a second part
um and and yeah you're right like like
the book does have a slow first half and
a sudden explosive ending
um so it does kind of make sense and I
mean also like it all depends on how
they edit the trailer right like it it
seems like the movie's full of
explosions and fight scenes but maybe
those are just the bits that they've
included in the trailer depending on how
they edit it
um you know maybe they showed us like
most of what the fight scenes and stuff
are and maybe the movie itself will be a
little slower than this trailer seems
yeah I think it's also it relates to
like the difference between the way
Frank Herbert writes and the way like
Cinema necessarily has to be because in
Dune like the violence is always
understated there'll be battles that
happen off screen like that's not the
point you know what I mean but when it
comes to a film especially like an epic
sci-fi movie it's kind of like you need
to show it you need to show more of the
battles probably you need to show more
the explosions to emphasize like the
cost of it all that there's life being
lost it's not like yeah it's not like a
book where you're reading it
yeah yeah it's true and I mean the book
the book does that to an extent that is
is almost frustrating like there's that
bit where
um
two years pass and we get back to Paul
and Paul is like hi and he's tripping
and he doesn't know when or where he is
and he remembers oh yeah like chani came
in the room the other day and and said
that she killed someone or Harris said
that Charney killed a man who wanted to
challenge a challenger and Paul's like
oh my God Johnny you killed someone and
she's like yeah no it's nothing you know
it's no big deal
um and it just happens off screen and
Paul's kind of like shook by it
um
and that's like all we get in terms of
Charney fighting in the entire Dune book
whereas this movie is now showing us you
know she's doing this crazy action
sequence where she's like bouncing
around and fighting all these Sada car
in the final battle and uh it's it's
it's so different I mean and it's
satisfying to see her in action because
the book tells her that she's a the book
tells us that she's a badass fighter now
we get to actually see it
yeah and it's awesome to see it and it
you made me think too it's it's
interesting how in the book we don't
really see Johnny fight but still I have
this image of her as like this kind of
badass fighter Warrior just because of
the way like she's presented and
especially that first book
um and yeah in the second book too she
still has that um that Vibe but yeah
it's awesome to actually see it in
action yeah for sure and I think I think
a few people have pointed out how this
shot in particular parallels the shot
that we got of Paul and the first
trailer from his vision yeah so that's
an interesting thing that they've done I
wonder like what the implication of that
is well it almost makes me wonder if
this shot is in fact another Vision not
reality yeah
um like I wonder if this is a nightmare
that Paul is having where he is he's
seeing his precious beloved Johnny in
this dangerous situation because you
know there's also the shot of him like
screaming her name and it it has the
feeling of a nightmare to me
um I
I get what you mean yeah it makes me
wonder if yeah he's just seeing like a
possible future oh yeah I don't know
maybe this is this is crazy speculation
tinfall but maybe he's like seeing a
future where like he maybe dies and then
Shawnee is like enraged and like gives
her life on the battlefield fighting in
his name or something like that I don't
know
and and I think that doing weird stuff
like that would be totally in keeping
with the way that the book handles
Visions because like you know as I said
like there's that chapter where we we
are in Paul's head and Paul doesn't know
what's real like Paul is so overwhelmed
by the spice and by his visions that
he's like I don't know if this is a
memory that happened in the past or a
vision that happened in the future I
don't know what's going on I don't know
what's real and and you know and and the
reader doesn't know what's real and so
yeah if the trailer gives us shots you
know perhaps like this and we as viewers
are like is this reality or is this a
vision that would be great like we
should be disoriented and we we should
be like activating our brains and
thinking like trying to figure out
what's real in the same way that Paul is
I think that would be really interesting
if they played with that
I do think that would be really
interesting just like I I really enjoy
that type of cerebral visualization type
thing in like science fiction and I
think that's something that I think like
1970s sci-fi is like really like good
for yeah um is that it's just their way
of visually representing esoteric or
abstract things like that
um and I think
um yeah it'd be cool it'd be cool if to
see some of that and we'll know who's
doing part two
yeah totally that that's something that
I think the previous adaptations like
the 84 Lynch movie and the 2000 sci-fi
mini series did like a fairly good job
of was like doing that like trippy crazy
Vision psychedelic stuff
um absolutely and and that's important
because it's such it it is in the book
like when Jessica does the Water of Life
ceremony and there's this incredibly
trippy sequence where Jessica's like
whoa I can see the mind of my unborn
child Aaliyah and I'm connecting with
romalo and we're sharing our brains and
it's it it's incredibly psychedelic and
I'm really really really curious to see
how vilnov does that in June part 2.
I'm super excited to see how he does it
and you know honestly here's something I
would say that might surprise people is
that I'd be excited to see how David
Lynch would have done that now with
modern technology because when it comes
to David Lynch he's all about the trippy
cerebral weird visualizations of stuff I
don't know if you've seen or heard of
Twin Peaks yeah that's like one of it's
his magnum opus to me it's just so
freaking weird the way he portrays like
interdimensional beings or whatever is
so bizarre so I'd love to see what his
would look like but Phil nov it's going
to be interesting it's going to be
interesting to see how that's visualized
because
I think a lot of people or a few people
have been saying like oh maybe Ali is
not going to be in the movie and I'm
like that's I feel like it would be
almost impossible to not have Aaliyah as
a character in this movie
so um
yeah I agree it's gonna be interesting
and Alia has already been in the movie
Aaliyah was in the first movie in that
Vision we got to see baby Aaliyah so
it's like there's no way they're not
going to include Aaliyah at this point
shortly
so I'm wondering too if we're gonna get
like some like weird uh CGI
visualization of like a of a fetus or
something
because in the book it's described as so
like trippy she's like in this like
weird mind space and she can see the
wild Reverend mother and she's
communicating with her and she kind of
like looks inside of herself and she's
like oh you're pregnant you didn't
really even tell us that they were gonna
that you were pregnant This is Gonna
Change the baby too
so like I feel like that's a scene I
feel that that scene's important for the
audience to understand why Aaliyah comes
out the way she does
yeah that that's the thing that's the
thing like in gene part one vilnov's
approach to the strangeness and the
trippiness of June has been I think very
understated like I thought it was good
when you know the big egg Imperial ship
came down and the weird like masked
robed spacing Guild people came out and
it was like very strange and evocative
that moment and I think that did like a
good job of the weirdness but it wasn't
understated weirdness whereas like the
Elia Water of Life ceremony it it can't
be it should not be understated it
should be like in your face I think
because as you say like it's it's not
just a Vibe it's a plot point it is an
important plot point that Aaliyah is
exposed to a drug in the womb that opens
her mind and makes gives her a thousand
adult consciousnesses before she's even
born and like like it's a very specific
plot point that audiences need to
understand that needs to be explained to
the audience and like are they going to
actually explain it or are they going to
leave it to you and me to explain it to
people on YouTube yeah because it's like
it it's difficult to get that stuff
across Without Really clunky Exposition
or like in the Lynch movie when they had
voiceovers of the characters thinking
like it's I I think that vilnov did a
good job of getting that stuff across in
the first movie but there are some very
challenging scenes in this next movie
that are going to be hard to do without
expositing yeah and also guys yes we are
talking about spoilers but uh anyway
back to like Aaliyah yeah I think yeah I
think um
what's important too if um I I don't
know how they would get this across or
how they would visualize this but it
should be emphasized the great pain that
baby Aaliyah's Consciousness is in at
this point in time yeah because she's
literally being crushed by the weight of
ancestral memories all of these fully
developed adult voices like screaming in
her mind from the time that she's like
first conscious so
um I I I hopefully Villeneuve does
something to emphasize that uh or at
least like when viewing the scene we
should be of the understanding that this
is kind of a Dark Twisted thing that's
happening now yes like uh Jessica's
being elevated to our next level of
conscious Consciousness yes she's she's
becoming a reverend mother but it's kind
of a dark thing also that's being
imposed upon the child and I think that
should be emphasized because it's like I
think based on the trailer too
um this movie is gonna emphasize Paul's
pain and resentment towards Jessica a
bit more so than Dune itself does yeah
and I feel like it would be great to
also show how Jessica in doing what she
does as has also harmed her daughter
because that's a big part of children
I'm doing and I don't know if we're
gonna get to ever see that in cinematic
form but yeah yeah it all Builds on
itself
yeah I think one of the bits I really
enjoyed in June part one was when Paul
gets angry at Jessica and his set and
he's yelling at his mother saying you
Benny jesser it made me a freak and and
that that is something that is so real
in the book as well where Jessica feels
this guilt at what she has made her son
into
um and and as an aside like I I sort of
recently saw some takes online they were
arguing that like in book three children
of June Jessica's relationship with
faradon was something that I never quite
understood because there's this plotline
in book three when Jessica's training
this boy to be like a Bene Jesuit and
it's it's sort of about making the
remnants of house Carino into a
non-threat but at the time I didn't
really understand what the point of that
relationship was and I saw people online
arguing that it's like faradin becomes
like a surrogate son for Jessica because
Jessica like a Jessica's relationship
with her son Paul is broken like after
the events of G and Jessica just leaves
and we don't see her for the entire
second book and like she she just severs
her relationship with her son while he's
being Emperor and because she just can't
handle what he has become
um and also sorry I mean interrupt go on
I was just I was just gonna say and also
like um I feel like the exact quote but
I think she was referring to Alia in
this particular quote she says I fled in
Terror of what I had created yeah
um and it's like whoa it's like no she
gets it she gets what she's like kind of
Unleashed upon the world not just with
Paul but with Alia as well so yeah it's
interesting it's interesting to see her
guilt and see her like question what
she's done and feel remorse and yeah her
training ferritin is kind of a way of
like I don't know maybe she's thinking a
little bit let me do this right maybe I
can create something that's not like
yeah monstrous potentially yeah yeah I
think that's the implication she's like
well I I missed my son and my daughter
off of Beyond repair maybe this child
this Carino child I can put on a better
path
um
I think that's the implication it's so
dark and strange but but I think I think
they can do it like I I I I I really
like Rebecca Ferguson who plays Jessica
and yes I I think that part of why she
does such a great job of Jessica is that
like I was watching Silo this new TV
show have you seen that with Rebecca
I've been watching it as well yeah I've
only seen the first few episodes but
like she has a very similar performance
to June where it's all about like she
she is someone who's trying to sort of
stay calm and in control but you can see
that she has so much intense emotion
bubbling just below the surface that
she's just sort of holding within
herself and it's it's this incredibly
amazing performance where it is just so
apparent how much depth and turmoil is
going on within her and I think that's
perfect for Jessica because you know the
because the the challenge of Dune is how
do you visually
represent the internal turmoil and I
think that Rebecca Ferguson is a master
of that specific kind of acting
simmering anxiety says says disco J in
the live chat
and I think I definitely agree yeah go
on
I agree with I think Rebecca Ferguson's
performance in Dune is excellent and
I've seen people say she's too emotional
if any jazz or it shouldn't be emotional
shut up you're wrong
actually Vinnie Jesuit totally have
emotions the whole thing is like when
other people are around they're not
going to show you who they are like all
the times you really see Jessica with
her walls down in the original Dude like
she's alone or she's with Paul and she
can she can open up to Paul a little bit
I don't know so I feel like she she she
did a very good job of like Towing that
line she is full of emotion she is full
of like anxiety but like from the
opening scene of Doom like she doesn't
know if her son is gonna die or not so
um I don't know yeah I I I I love just
Rebecca Ferguson's portrayal I always
say Jessica Ferguson and so
yeah no I I completely agree I've also
seen people saying oh you know Jessica's
too emotional in the movie villagers are
unemotional you read the books they are
full of emotion and the books are
constantly saying and then Jessica used
her Benny Jesuit breathing exercises to
calm her mind and like it very
explicitly is saying that all the
characters are constantly wrestling for
control of their emotions and and using
Ben ages are at philosophy to do so no
one in these books is a robot the
butlerian Jihad happened for a reason
there are no robots everyone is deeply
human even the god Emperor worm God
later the second the most inhuman
character the most human yeah he's the
most human at the same time and that's
what these books are about these books
are about striving to transcend our
human weaknesses striving to unlock our
human potential but at the same time to
retain our humanity and it's about that
tension it's about how do we be better
smarter stronger how do we survive but
how do we also retain that kernel of
humanity that makes us who we are
and that's an interesting question that
a lot of Science Fiction uh deals with
and dune deals with it in a really
interesting way because a lot of Science
Fiction they take this idea about
maintaining humanity and they look at it
from like I don't know like a genetic
engineering standpoint or like a
transhumanism standpoint where it's like
if you replace all the parts when are we
no longer human but Dune deals with it
on like an on on the standpoint if I
think I don't know slow guided Evolution
yeah um and it's like it's about like um
I think Dune is about like picking out
what the traits of humanity that make us
human you know what I mean because the
Benny Jesuit have certain things that
they care about more than other things
right so the bidding each other are
totally not down with like something
like artificial insemination they feel
like that's a step too far they're not
down with things like direct genetic
manipulation I feel like that's a step
too far but they will like breed in
certain genes that they like through the
natural way so it's almost it's always
about
how do you stay human and how do you
evolve without taking it a step too far
and I feel like the way dude handles it
is very unique and I I haven't quite
seen anything similar really
yeah and obviously like the telexu are a
meditation on that because the chilak
zoo are these genetic Engineers who who
Tinker at the biology and the genetic
underpinnings of humanity and
um and I and I like how we got a slight
hint at that Vibe with the Monstrous
spider creature that we saw in part one
one definitely a play like suit design
yeah because like they did not need to
like tell us anything about what that
spider monster is it just told us that
in this universe there are Abominations
of a biological genetic nature like that
is a possibility that is lurking at the
corners of this universe and that is
something that we should fear you know
and if you if you look at how those holy
lacks were presented in the book it's
very clear that Frank Herbert is framing
this it's like a kind of a negative dark
thing
um because they're kind of considered
the dirty it's lilacsu the strange
tilaksu xenophobic tampering with all
sorts of horrible things and then way
later in the book we get to see their
Axolotl tanks for the first time and the
truth of it is like very horrifying and
it's very disturbing yeah so yeah
they're very they're framed as like like
Abominations they're framed as
abomination
which is like not to mention the
revelations in the later books when
they're like oh by the way the trilaxu
deliberately pretended to be stupid and
gross but they actually are secretly
um like a like a secret Immortal Muslim
cult
very confusing things going on in the
later books with like uh with WAFF and
and
cult is so interesting that's some of
the most interesting stuff in Heretics
of Dune especially seeing their
interactions with Betty Jesuit uh with
the Reverend mother how she just kind of
like toys with that's Layla Master using
religion because like that to me
inheritance of Dune that's like the best
uh those are some of the best scenes
where you get to see like Hands-On how
the Benny Jesuit manipulate through
religion how they just kind of broke the
play attacks around their little finger
it's so interesting yeah but that's
really deep in the series so I wouldn't
have to get into that yeah let's try and
stick to the uh the first book for now I
guess
um thanks for the donation from the
booty bamboozle who says hey guys I read
the main sixth June books after your
last stream and really enjoyed them is
there anything you hope they change from
the book for this movie I'm curious what
they do with Alia
what do you hope that they change
well there's certain things that I
already know they're changing that I
like which is um the the bigger role for
princess Ireland I think she'll have
more agency and the ultimate decision at
the end I think that's one thing they're
going to change I don't feel like it's
just gonna be like oh Paul says he wants
her and he just gets there I feel like
she'll probably be like okay I mean I
feel like she'll have more agency I I'm
I'm down for the expanded role of chani
um so that's cool yeah I don't know if I
have any direct oh oh one thing one
thing I would love this this is just
kind of like a wish I would love to see
villanov's take on a guild Navigator he
doesn't have to show that because it's
not really in the book we don't really
see a guild Navigator until the next
book yeah but I would love to see one I
would love to see it
yeah yeah as you say like yeah the first
book doesn't have a creepy fish man in a
tube
um like was in the Lynch movie but I
think that so many people are expecting
it because of the Lynch movie
um so I I would be surprised if they
didn't include it
um it'd be easy to do because the guild
is coming to Iraqis yeah at the end of
the book so I mean if you have your
opportunity
and I feel like everyone's coming to
miraculous and and I feel like
um Villanova is almost already done a
guild Navigator in arrival right because
you're right yeah a rival is is that
adaptation of that wonderful Ted Chang
short story uh and it's about this
linguist communicating with an alien and
the alien is a strange monster inside
this gaseous octopod cloudy uh space
that we only see vaguely through the
mist and it's um it's very similar to
how Guild Navigators appear so he could
easily like transfer some of those ideas
into a depiction of The Navigators
I'd love to see it I'd love to see
villanov's Dark Twisted take I want to
Guild Navigator looks like
yeah I think that could be really cool
um because we haven't had like a good
design I don't know some people hate the
David Lynch design but we haven't had
like a reasonable design I feel like a
reasonably good looking design since the
David Lynch one because the Sci-Fi mini
series one doesn't necessarily work I
don't think it looks good at all but um
the David Lynch one it looks like this
this mutated creature like you can say
that at the very least it looks like a
mutated creature or something that's
been that's really old and that's been
mutated by spice so yeah yeah I don't
know like the Lynch movie looks but the
Lynch Navigator looks a bit too much
like a piece of human anatomy that's
been stuck in a jar to me and I'm not
gonna say exact piece of human anatomy
looks like several of them yeah yeah
it's uh it's it's very ugly which I
guess is like this yeah I I hate its
mouth orifice thing like the more you
look at it the worse this thing is
um
I I think this like uh 2003 children of
June mini-series is like fairly faithful
I mean it's it's closer for sure yeah
like it's to the book The CGI has aged
badly but in terms of like faithfulness
to the book I think this is pretty close
to what The Navigators should look like
because they're described as having like
the webbed hands and just kind of like
fishmen swimming around
um because edrick isn't like some fat
big headed guy that's like you can move
around in his tank yeah exactly yeah
he's like quite human-like and and that
I think is like part of what is
sorry is like a funny character because
he's like kind of pathetic and he's he's
the guy at the meeting who everyone is
like putting on because he's not
very smart and everyone's he's only
there to like Shield everybody from
Paul's prescience and so now that's
that's the scene I want to see adapted I
would love to see that scene that you're
talking about from uh dude Messiah where
they're all just sitting around you got
the Benny Jesuit you got the princess
you got the guild Navigator you got the
the face dancer that's something I would
love to see yeah yeah I I think we've
talked before about how hilarious we
both find that scene
um it's so silly but like so awesome at
the same time
it's something that only could have come
out of like uh 60s early 70s sci-fi yeah
yeah right yeah it's like the most
Eisley Cantina just like these goofy
gooey looking dudes in rubber suits just
having a business meeting that's just
hilarious um which you know I I kind of
struggle to imagine Villeneuve doing
that in such a goofy way and and that's
one of like the questions for me about
the June part 2 movie is are they going
to capture the goofiness of like
specifically the ending of June
um because like yeah we've talked before
about how funny we find that like the
dialogue with like Aaliyah and the
emperor when he's going on about like
and assassin him yeah she is just
this two-year-old child is just sassing
the emperor of the universe and he is
not understanding what is going on and
there's all this dialogue are you
reading my mind and like it's all this
completely comedic farcical it's a farce
and I and that is such a break from the
tone of especially the June part 1 movie
which is which is so much like this
Serene beautiful contemplative
philosophical visually beautiful movie
so like how
how will villnove handle these more
ridiculous scenes in the movie will he
keep the Ridiculousness of it or will he
make it more sort of serious you know
I've often thought about how he's going
to handle the emperor meeting Aaliyah
scene with the Reverend mother and all
that and I think I think he could keep
that scene and I think he could do it
but I do think he would he would have to
significantly change the tone I think
that you just gotta make Aaliyah more
creepy
make things more dark make the emperor
less oh what's going on
and make the Reverend mother like less
reactionary screaming
um I don't know just tone things down a
bit I could see him like
um brushing his tone over the whole
thing and giving it a nice Villeneuve
coating
to like kind of tone down the Goof
Factor just a little bit if you watch
the David Lynch version of that scene
the David Lynch version of that scene is
freaking hilarious I I'm pretty sure
it's unintentional but the way the way
the baron
diesel is so funny he like floats out
like screaming and like does a bunch of
tumbles and he just like floats out into
the distance after Elia poisons him and
like the wall breaks open right at the
right moment it's like a sitcom or
something he's like he's like a a popped
balloon careening around the room
letting its air out yeah completely
ridiculous I I included that shot at the
start of the real June video that I did
um because it is just the most concise
way to show the complete Ridiculousness
of the Lynch movie
so yeah I mean like I I I hope that they
capture some of that Ridiculousness in
the movie but as you say like I think
it's more likely that Villeneuve just
makes it a bit more
serious and like tones that down a
little bit which you know like I
I think there's a risk that that takes
away part of the point of the ending of
the book because I think part of the
part of the point of the ending is that
it's it's just weird and sort of
anticlimactic and unsatisfying for
everybody involved but like I I think
that you know Studios and audiences may
expect and may want a more satisfying
more climactic ending and so I I sort of
worry that you know that they may go too
far in trying to make it more the same
to other stories you know give us give
us the expected endings because like in
the trailer
we see
Gurney Alec facing beast robon and so
like it looks like there's going to be a
final fight where Gurney gets to kill
raban
but like I think part of the point of
the book is that Gurney's like hey Paul
let me fight fade you promised me I'll
get to get revenge against the Hawkings
and Paul's like nah you're not gonna get
that you don't get it yeah what it's
like um
I understand the pressure to give in you
know to like the audience pressure
sometimes people just really want click
game ball and you gotta give it to them
but I I I yeah I I I don't know I feel
like Villeneuve is gonna mainly do what
he wants I don't I don't deny that the
studio is definitely gonna have like
some input and I feel like if they did
like do like I don't know like a test
screening and people hated the ending I
don't doubt that they might have they
would have like
uh added additional
scenes in or additional moments to make
things more climactic and epic and I
don't necessarily mind that kind of
thing because I like I said it's like
it's kind of the natural trade-off when
it comes to adaptations you're never
gonna get a one-to-one adaptation it's
just like not possible and certain
things just don't translate on screen
like I'm pretty sure it's been a while
since I read through all of Doom but I'm
pretty sure that Rabon doesn't die
doesn't die on screen we kind of hear
about it later yeah so um I think with
with a movie
we gotta see him die and I mean we can't
just hear about it later we gotta see
him die sorry guys yes spoilers we're
doing spoilers today
should I put spoilers in the title maybe
I should put spoilers perhaps I've been
seeing people comment
um yeah I mean look it would kind of be
fan service but like
I part of me would love it if we get to
see Josh Brolin do a bunch of flips and
cut off her Bond's head and do a little
dance like sure like it would it would
be cool and fun but part of me is also
like wouldn't it be cool if he was
fighting raban and then raban like got
away and Gurney was yeah real just angry
and frustrated and it's like why don't I
get the violent Vengeance that I want
um that that might be a way giving us a
cool fight scene but also giving us the
sort of
deliberate like narrative blue balls
that Frank Herbert gives us in the book
that's what he likes to do it would be
in keeping with what Frank Herbert likes
to do for sure yeah so like I feel like
there are like clever things they could
they could do but um
yeah so many possibilities
do you want to talk about uh Johnny and
like some of the changes they seem to be
making with Chinese Raw
yeah well definitely she's having like a
more expanded role and I did hear a line
for her from her in the trailers
something to the effect of this prophecy
is how they control us or something like
that yeah which is interesting
because Shawnee in the book is a is a
True Believer at least for at least as
far as I can tell she's a True Believer
she believes in Paul in fact in the
second one
I forget which if it's in Dune or doing
Messiah but actually she almost like
doesn't understand when he can't see
something in the future she's like I
don't understand like can't you just use
your power to do it or something yeah so
it's like um so it was interesting to
have her questioning things here because
that's definitely an addition definitely
an addition
yeah yeah I feel like Chinese role in
the book is that she's not super engaged
with Paul's
prophet
prescience magic situation like I feel
like their relationship is about just
being human and grounded and normal
together like that there's that I mean
that's kind of how their relationship
starts is that Paul's having all these
crazy visions and Charney is there with
him I mean it's like you know someone's
tripping too hard at a party and she's
like you know holding Paul's hair
you know like you tell me if you're home
like she is grounded him and looking
after him and that's how they get
together
um and so like I feel like their
relationship is founded on her not being
overly interested in his magic space
Jesus Shenanigans she's just like she
just loves the man Paul and and he she's
she's like his his final tie to like
Humanity you know because Jessica as the
book goes on Paul becomes increasingly
less human in a way yeah and I I feel
like that's part of what like kind of
like separates him from Jessica and kind
of may be part of the reason that
Jessica like leaves a wreck is but I
think that Shawnee is his one thing that
grounds him to his Humanity throughout
Dune and throughout dude Messiah up
until the very end
yeah so um yeah
yeah see that is part of her role she is
like the the last thread of of Paul's
Humanity through like book two and so
when she spoilers when Charlie dies at
the end of book two that's what breaks
Paul and that's why he walks into the
desert and tries to commit suicide
because like she was the last thread of
his humanity and so when when she's gone
he just can't take it anymore
can't take it that's the destruction of
Paul Atreides and that's why that's part
of the reason that a lot of people can't
hang with Dune Messiah because
um as far as
um as much as the original Dune kind of
blue balls you it gives you like an
ending it gives you like a climactic and
you get your thing you get your it
happens dude Messiah is not like that
dude Messiah is very much oh okay that's
the end of it and it's very very
deflating and it's very sad to see your
hero undone in that way and it's
something that people are not used to
reading so that that to me is the
question I don't know I don't know how
something like that would be adapted I
don't know if you could do just a movie
on doing Messiah which was part of the
reason I think the original mini-series
kind of did dude Messiah and Children of
Dune in the same thing because to end in
on Dune Messiah is like ah ouch yeah
yeah if you think that Dune one has a
frustrating anticlimactic unsatisfying
ending who boy is June Messiah worst
like Gene Messiah is so much more
anticlimactic and frustrating and
depressing sad yeah yeah
like I I like I I don't think a faithful
adaptation of June Messiah as a movie
would be fun for anybody I don't know if
it's the movie that anybody needs right
now I don't think Studios would like it
I don't think focus group testing would
like it I I mean part of me wants to see
it but I I don't think it would be a
great use of 100 million dollars or
whatever movies cost to make now yeah
here's the real deal I think that I
don't know if it could happen I really
think that if we were going to continue
Dune in the best way possible it might
be what we would have to do is
go on the Children Of Tune and then the
rest of it is told through like
flashbacks or maybe we have a I don't
know I don't know I feel even that might
be a little clunky but like I feel like
Doom aside doesn't work as a movie I
just know it doesn't and I love the book
and I love Dune I love the book but I
don't I don't think it works as a movie
I really don't
yeah I mean well why not continue as a
TV series because like they are TV
series they are making or were
attempting to make a dune TV show called
The Sisterhood
um why not just adapt the following
books as a TV show instead because like
like this the scale
is smaller in Messiah and as well
compared to June like it's funny because
most book series get that the scale
increases and the stakes increase as it
goes on but Dune is not quite like that
because like all the big giant battles
happen in at the end of the first book
whereas the following books are mostly
just about a very small cast of
characters and like yes Paul is like
emperor of the universe but like we
don't really see any large scale stuff
Indian Messiah was mostly just Paul
what's so awesome about doing Messiah
and I know this is the same reason that
a lot of people hate it is that the
action happens off screen mostly like oh
there's this 10 years or so I forget
exactly how long in between doing and
doing Messiah but there's some time in
between doing and doing Messiah and in
that time space 60 billion people have
died as the result of Paul atrey and his
Jihad and we saw none of that it all
happened off screen so we just we were
just like throwing in and here's Paul
years later
completely just like riddled with like
guilt he's like completely changed and
it's not the Paul that you remember from
the first book really he he has changed
like the one of the first scenes that
you get with him is him like denying a
constitution and being like there will
be no Constitution you have no rights
basically yeah so it's like and he
Compares himself to Hitler but it's it's
crazy because it's like what's what's
good about it it's like when did this
happen like I didn't see this happen it
happened off screen so it's it's just
really interesting the way it's handled
and and it sort of takes you multiple
readings of Dune to sort of make sense
of it I I think
um and and when you do go back to the
first book and you really pay attention
it's sort of like well hang on like I it
the signposting was there like when you
threads were there like there's all
these little details that like the first
time you read June you're like oh
deep made drums out of the human skin of
his enemies huh yeah that's weird I
wonder what that's about but but then
like you get to Messiah and you're like
oh no that yeah that was real that
that's really who this guy is like he is
you know this this warlord who
sterilizes planets and like yeah like he
doesn't like it and he feels like he has
to go along with it and you know there's
all this it's complicated but um but it
but all the hints are there
and two there's that idea that um
that when someone is playing a role in
society when that person is removed from
that role another person steps in to
fill it yeah and it's almost like Paul
has become
the thing he was fighting against in the
first book and that's what's devastating
and that is I think that that's the core
of Frank Herbert's point it's like
that's the hero that you were fighting
for but like I mean look what happens
when you like blindly follow someone he
blindly let all these frim into their
deaths let them on this Jihad and then
their culture at the end is like in in
tatters they're like a pale shadow of
what they used to be
it's just it's really interesting
yeah it's like do you the gene book
series is like a bait and switch where
it's like hey guys do you like sci-fi
Heroes here's a cool sci-fi hero called
Paula tradies and he's gonna help the
fremen and save the world it's gonna be
awesome he's gonna beat the evil
harkenings and Carinos and and then it
suckers you in to thinking that Paula
trades is a cool guy and then like the
following four books is Frank punishing
us for ever thinking that following a
hero is a good idea because it gives you
the Jihad and it gives you the
oppression of later the second and it
gives you all the consequences uh it
gives you the Carinos coming back and
and and it gives you all of the horrible
consequences of Paul's Uprising and so
it's yeah it's All About That central
point about the dangers of following a
hero and and I'm really glad that you
know the the villanue of movie seems to
be really trying to capture that and
seems to be voicing that by saying the
prophecy is how they enslave us and and
by looking all cross when when Paul
plays Messiah so I I'm hopeful that the
movie will try to capture that
I think that one of Frank Herbert's
points too is that
being a hero or greatness is not
consistent like it's like someone can be
a hero and do a heroic thing at some
point you can Liberate the Furman but
does that mean that person is always
going to be a hero I think that in
society will have someone that behaves
heroically and does a great thing and so
they're labeled a hero by society and
people kind of get this idea that they
can do no wrong so people are very
shocked when someone that they've
labeled as a hero is now doing wrong
things because being a hero is not
consistent being great is not consistent
and I feel like understanding that is
key to leadership and I think that's
also a point that Frank Herbert is
making having like that sense of uh of
the sardonic having the ability to look
within yourself and not buy into your
own myth is key to actually ruling
effectively yeah I think one of the
interesting angles is that
part of it is that it's not just about
the individual it's about the broader
context like Frank Frank is always
telling us Indian to broaden our
perspective and see the interconnections
like with his ecology environment stuff
um I think part of the point is that
it's saying that like it doesn't really
matter whether Paul
agrees or disagrees with the Jihad and
and the fremin Empire it doesn't really
matter what his personal feelings are
what matters is the consequences of his
actions and the Jihad is a consequence
of his actions
um his his actions cause disaster
whether he feels good about it or not
you know and so yeah and and and he
thinks about how you know this this will
go on with or without me you know so
it's sort of about how the individual
doesn't matter in the face of these
broader political and religious forces
sometimes it's immortal
yeah going
I was going to say what I like about
that first dude movie is what I felt was
like a was dennyville showing us like an
exact moment
where Paul chooses to go forward on the
path it's the moment where Jessica's
like we can find a way off arrakis yeah
and then he says no I'm gonna stay yeah
knowing that staying on Iraqis leads to
the Jihad so he makes the decision he
makes the active choice to avenge how to
treaties even though
it's going to cause all of this death
yeah I so I really like that because it
shows his agency
I agree I agree so much because yeah
that's like a subtle change that is like
quite significant in hindsight and and
it's the ending of the first movie
because like in the book like there's no
question that they're gonna stay with
the Freeman because that's their only
choice but but in the movie Jessica is
like hey let's leave the planet help us
get off the planet and that's not a
thing that happens in the book but as
you say yeah it gives it makes it a
choice and that means that everything
that happens afterwards uh is more
meaningful because Paul chose it
yeah
I one one thing like you know it in
terms of like Paul's subtle turn towards
causing atrocities like there are these
like subtle references in towards the
end of the book where we start to see
Paul doing these horrible things that
really kind of shocked me on reread
um like right towards the end before the
final battle it's mentioned like still
gar and Gurney and Paul are talking and
and I think I think Gurney brings up
that oh so all those civilians from the
villagers all those refugees who came to
us uh are you still planning on using
them as shock troops and cannon fodder
and sending them against the sadakar
like and Paul's like oh yeah we're doing
that we're doing that we're sending the
civilians can and father and Gurney's
like they're all gonna die like you know
that right Paul like all these civilians
are gonna get slaughtered by this
article and Paul is like yeah yeah
that's fine they know the odds like
every side of card I managed to kill is
one fewer for us and it's like wow he
doesn't care about the expenditure of
human life
yeah it is inconsiderate of it
yeah and like I I really hope they
include some of that in the movie I I
feel like they won't I feel like they
won't have Timothy chalamet sending
civilian refugees to be slaughtered but
it's such an important part of the book
that that is where he's headed you know
absolutely yeah and it kind of reminds
me of one of my favorite what's now one
of my favorite animes Attack on Titan it
does a very similar thing oh yeah with
the hero where he takes this
slow turn to being like kind of a
genocidal maniac and I feel like yeah so
I do see that yeah that's definitely
something that's there and that Darkness
from Paul is something that needs to be
emphasized so people understand that
because I still feel like I get people
arguing with me that Paul like oh Paul
is more innocent than I present in my
videos or whatever and like I really
don't think so I really think that at
some point he made the decision to care
about his Vengeance more than the life
that would be expended
yeah yeah that's very much what the book
is doing I think and it is like not
immediately obvious the first time you
read it but and part of it of course is
is the prescience you know like like
Paul sees the future he feels like it's
already happened and so he he's
desensitized to the horror because he
has seen billions die in his nightmares
constantly and it's like it's already
happened to him so it's like well of
course he doesn't care about a bunch of
civilians dying because he knows the
stakes he knows the scale he is Godlike
and that makes you less human and that
is of course part of God emperor of Dune
with with lato you know power and and
knowledge can be dehumanizing and that's
one of this and that comes back to that
Central tension of Dune is that Dune is
about attaining knowledge and attaining
power and unlocking your potential but
it's also about the dangers of doing so
because it makes you less human
yeah and once you become disconnected
from the rest of humanity it's like I
don't know if you become this weird
thing that's outside of humanity which
is discussed in God improved Judah Bunch
um Leto he exists within humanity and
yet he is outside of humanity and that's
what makes him like a god like the
truest God that Humanity has ever seen
because he has like he has he has the
history of humanity all of it within him
and also all of Humanity's future like
within him so I it's interesting and
it's interesting also to
to look at the difference between Paul
and his son and how the and how one is
able to somehow hold on to the threat of
his Humanity right up until the very end
even though he's the most inhuman human
that's ever existed and one
somehow his Humanity drifts away from
him
and he's left as like a shell of what he
used to be
it's interesting there are so many
fascinating ironies with later II in
that like as you say like he is a mind
made up of human Minds like he has all
the past human consciousnesses inside
him and there's something ironic about
having all these billions of human Minds
inside him is what makes him less human
um it's like it's like the the sum is
more than the the parts like the being a
collective of everything makes you
something different to what an
individual human mind is and and like
also there's the irony of that you know
later God Emperor lato does what he does
to save Humanity his purpose is to save
Humanity from Extinction and the way
that he saves humanity is by oppressing
and crushing Humanity in a inhuman
inhumane cruel way so so there's all
these sort of ironies and recursions
where it's like being inhuman to save
Humanity unlocking and increasing your
Humanity but losing touch with the
humans around you it's constantly like
circling and looping around these
questions of what does it mean to be
human
yeah later II had to like instill this
message and kind of the collective
unconscious the collective conscious of
mankind and it's this lesson about
giving your power over to leaders but
his plan is is so multifaceted like
that's one aspect of it and then there's
the more like I guess like practical
aspect of it which he's trying to Shield
Humanity from some prescient enemy some
vague prescient Intercity entity coming
into the future well by by literally
changing our DNA but that's the other
side of that
yeah the uh the one of many faces
all the ones of many faces it's it's
it's kind of vague
it's I've I've yeah we could get into a
whole long discussion about who leicho's
great enemy could potentially be let's
not open that door right now yeah yeah I
think we'll we'll have a different
stream sometime to talk about yeah the
ending of the later books but uh I think
you and I both have a suspicion that the
great enemy is not ominous the evil
Skynet robot
absolutely not
how about we answer some super chats uh
thank you Adam who says Charney was
having dreams about Paul before meeting
him I don't like how part two handles
the relationship between the two is is
that true does Charlie have dreams about
Paul before they meet I don't remember
that
I don't remember that either is someone
there's someone in the chat remember
that because I'm lost I don't remember I
don't remember hearing anything about
that unless that's something from the
Brian Herbert
yeah it's a good point that might be a
that might be a Brian Herbert thing he
makes a lot of in-between books so I
mean
yeah that's always the danger of
prequels and stuff everything was
foreseen everything was pre-planned
everything was destined you do that too
much and it's no longer a story it's a
you know it's a it's it's all prophecy
or whatever
um but I mean in in terms of the
relationship of Paul and Charney more
generally I mean I'll note that of
course Paul does have dreams of shiny
before they meet maybe Adam was confused
though but in terms of their
relationship generally like I I I talked
about this in the video I just released
um where it seems like Paul and Johnny
have this super interesting tension
um in the new movie where they love each
other and they have this deep personal
connection but they have a political
disagreement where chani believes that
the prophecy enslaves the fremant which
is true like she sees the manipulation
of the benedozer at least on algaebe
stuff
um and she looks really angry Charlie
looks mad when Paul is playing Messiah
so like I'm so curious about what they
do with Poland Chinese relationship when
it's like you know I love you but please
stop oppressing my culture like oh my
God
that's gonna be interesting I don't
think they're gonna change it
um so much where Johnny is not still
like by Paul's side by the end of it so
I feel like at some point she's gonna
have to accept what's happening which
will be interesting to see it'll be
interesting to see how she finally how
she chooses Paul over the Freeman really
you know what I mean yeah and I also
think that in this movie they're kind of
um juxtaposing chani and stilgar where
you've got stilgar who's like really
really like he just really is believing
Paul and I think the conversation I
think what Shawnee is saying might be to
stilgar I think that some of those lines
in the trailer we might be seeing an
argument between Johnny and stilgar like
when he's saying I don't care but what
you believe is what I believe uh I think
he's probably talking to Johnny rather
than Paul I thought it was Paul at first
but it's probably Johnny saying
something like this prophecy is meant to
enslave us and him saying I don't care
what you believe it's about what I
believe or maybe that's Paul's standing
right there it kind of looks like Paul's
hair yeah
it's also curious to see stilgar wounded
incidentally yeah because that's like I
think I've been in the book
it might have been after a battle or
something
perhaps it really does seem like there's
going to be a lot more violence in the
movie than it is in the book
um but but yeah I agree that I think
that it is cool and interesting how
they're setting up this Duality or this
difference between stilgar who's like
super on board with the prophecy and
chani who is super not on board with the
prophecy
um I think that's a good idea because in
the book it's a lot more subtle where
basically all of the foramen are like
yeah yeah let's do it the prophecy's
real Paul is the savior and it's only
like really subtle when Jessica is like
oh this this feels kind of bad
exploiting this culture and like Paul is
like oh you know stilgar is becoming uh
I'm losing a friend and gaining a a
follower and it's like it's a lot more
subtle whereas I think for the purposes
of a Hollywood movie I think that it
makes a lot of sense to actually make it
more explicit and to have chani say hey
no this is bad I think that makes sense
but like how did they say yeah but how
do they resolve it like like like is
there going to be a scene where Chinese
like well it sucks that you're
exploiting my culture and lying to my
people and I think that you're full of
but I you're Timothy chalamet so
it's fine I will choose you instead of
my entire culture like how is that not
enormously dark and cynical you know
it is and I think that Johnny is gonna
have to ask herself that question like
what's the solution to this yeah how
could this not happen the only way is
Paul's death
so do you choose your love
or do you choose the Freeman yeah that's
her that's her test that's her struggle
that's her Arc and I think if they're
really going to do that the way we think
they're going to do it I mean that
that's that's brilliant and I'm looking
forward to see how it plays out because
it's very complex and it's not an arc
that you typically see it's a very it's
very I don't know it's hard it's hard
yeah yeah it's interesting
yeah I I think that it it is a good and
interesting question to ask like like it
feels it feels like this isn't something
that they're like shoehorning in like
this is a real concern in the book that
they are giving more attention because
it deserves more attention
um so yeah I'm cautiously optimistic
about this plotline
um I was gonna say yeah sorry well I
think that it's important to emphasize
the LIE of it all the LIE of the
prophecy and what the vinegars are doing
because I think that is something that's
more or less missing from like I think
General people's understanding of Doom
like a lot of people have have seen the
David Lynch movie and that's what they
know about Doom they don't realize that
the prophecy is a lie they don't realize
that the freemin are being abused and
manipulated right so I feel like if as
did Evil know as the person that's
bringing Doom to this generation of
people I think it's important for him to
emphasize that and I think he knows that
because I think he understands it's
important to the its importance to the
overall narrative and it's something
like I said was totally missing from the
David Lynch version of Doom like David
Lynch did not do that aspect at all Paul
is 100 the Messiah and he makes it rain
at the end so yeah it's a key difference
and it needs to be emphasized
yeah yeah
um Ferdinand in the live chat asks can
you explain more how Paul is exploiting
the foramen
um and I think it is important to
clarify I I mean I think the short
version of it is that the Benny Jesuit
have an entire
organization called the mission area
productiva and the panoplica propheticus
and like they have this whole
scheme where for thousands of years they
deliberately plant religious ideas in
cultures all across the universe and
it's stuff like you know there will be
this Reverend mother who has special
powers and special knowledge and and she
will have she will make all these cool
things happen for you
she'll have a son and you can trust
these people and these people have your
best interests at heart and that's the
LIE of it it's not true that the Ben
ages are at care about all these random
cultures all around the universe the
reality is that the bandages are a plant
these ideas as a way to influence
cultures around the Galaxy so that when
they go somewhere they can assume that
oh yeah there are religious ideas
planted here that I can exploit if I
pretend to fit the signs if I protect if
I say the right words I can make these
people do what I want it's it's a plan
of manipulation and so like the LIE is
that the fremen and the lesson prophecy
the prophecy suggests that Paul and
Jessica are here to save the fremen and
help the fremen
but that's not true the reality is that
Paul and Jessica are there to advance
the political goals of house at tradies
to recapture Iraqis for their own
purposes and so
Paul's conquest of Iraqis does not
ultimately help the foramen
is that a good summary Quinn I think you
explained it succinctly I think that was
a great great summary of the Benny
Jesuit exploitation yeah basically
it's basically everything you said the
Vinnie Jesuit seeded myths that formed
into Legends and and uh religions on
many different planets not just Iraqis
and it's basically just in case they
ever need these people and they're also
they've been interested have also been
doing this whole thing where they've
been tinkering with Bloodlines to create
this person called the quizlet's
Cataract that's who Paul Mayer may not
be potentially
um and the quiz that's had Iraq would
help the Benny Jesuit
um
uh I guess um would help the Benny
Jesuit lead the universe the human
Universe down the path that they best
saw fit in their theory in their design
and also um the missionar protectiva is
meant to kind of prepare the world for
his coming you know they seeded all
these things so that when the world so
when they decide to reveal the quiz
that's had Iraq the people are ready and
the people are already open to it
because the mini Jesuit had already
seeded the myths and legends
yeah
and another angle to it is is the
ecological transformation of arrakis
um because you know there's the whole
idea seeded by kinds about how the
Furman want to change the desert Planet
arrakis into a green Paradise
um and so the foramen sort of expect
that the lesson will help them make
arrakis into a paradise but what the
later books explore like I mean like
when Paul and Jessica get there they're
like oh yeah yeah fine yeah sure we'll
turn arachus into a green Paradise sure
whatever but the later books explore the
consequences of that transformation and
how it is ultimately not in the
Freeman's best interests to turn arachas
into a green paradise and that It
ultimately destroys their culture
because their culture is based on being
a desert people
um and so it it destroys them to to
change Iraqis and there's no more worms
or spice if you if you destroy the
deserts so um that so yeah like as you
say it's complicated because like the
quizzes cataract thing means that Paul
kind of is a real super powerful person
who can change the world but but the LIE
is that this is all for the foramen
because it just ain't
and like you said there is a sense of
cultural loss that permeates Dune
Messiah and Children of Dune where the
Freeman are concerned
um just there's a sense of cultural
degradation and then by the time we see
the remnants of the Freeman and God
emperor of Dune they are now Museum
Freeman they're now just a farce they're
just like this ridiculous imitation of
something that once was great yeah um
and it said it's sad the Freeman die
essentially
yeah yeah it's such a gut punch when
Duncan sees the museum for eminent is
like wow like this is the consequence
this is what it was all for this is the
result of of all the prophecy this just
this pale imitation and and you know
like we only really get the full
revelation of that in those later books
but you know the closest thing we get to
showing us that in the first Union book
is is still go and that's why I'm really
glad that they seem to be paying a lot
of attention to stilgar's ah I love it
um because stillgar is he's sort of the
beginning of that he's sort of the
beginning of that downfall because
stillgar is such this powerful
charismatic
independent guy and seeing him become
this sort of
starry-eyed religious zealot serving
Paul is just so depressing and so I
really don't know
you see the whole cycle in in stilgar's
Arc through uh up in up through uh
Children of Dune right so you see how he
becomes
radicalized how he becomes a True
Believer and then you see slowly over
time how he's disenfranchised like it
starts with him asking questions and not
understanding Paul and doing Messiah and
then by Children of Dune he's wondering
if he should kill Paul's abomination of
children like you know I mean he's he
completely goes from like believing
fully
to questioning things yeah to like
realizing that he's been essentially
lied to and calling this caught in this
really weird place where he's like yeah
I'm I serve House of Trades but I also
realize the things that I used to
believe weren't necessarily accurate to
reality
yeah yeah because it's not just some
completely linear straightforward
character Arc he does he is this
intelligent guy who has so many back and
forths and and so many doubts that he's
wrestling with and yeah as you say
children of June book three does such a
good job of exploring that and um I
still go interrogates what he believes
yeah it's one of the most interesting
character Journeys I think in the whole
series that along with I think Aaliyah
and of course Paul but yeah
yeah it's interesting to see that
because stilgar always is kind of
relegated to a side character he's never
really like a main character but he is
like
I don't know we see we see Paul in a
different light through stilgar's eyes
you know yeah if that makes any sense
I I think part of how it works like I
mean people always ask why does Duncan
Idaho get resurrected thousands of times
um why is Duncan Idaho hanging around in
thousands of years in the future because
why does the guy because he's just a guy
because like the main characters of June
Paul and lato and everyone and tag like
they constantly are becoming completely
different organisms and they and they
have these enormous philosophical
ideological shifts and plans like they
are they are unrelatable characters we
need to have a constant we need to have
a relatable average ish human person who
we can see through their eyes and so we
it's like the control in a scientific
experiment it's like Duncan is always
the same but how does Duncan view the
the dependent variable the changing
thing like how does Duncan view the
changing situation
um that was why the god emperor
particular like brought them back over
and over and over again he was like his
grounding point to not only that place
in time but just like I don't he I
Duncan I feel like Duncan's reactions to
the things that leito was doing were
very important to Leto it was very
important for him for him to see and
understand that and it's also just like
so funny when Duncan wakes up
in God Emperor days and he's just like
what the flip is going on what is all
this this is so weird uh it's
interesting to see that because he's the
only one that points out how weird
everything is and I need that in that in
that book you need someone to just be
like okay this is weird but okay yeah
yeah in a book about a thousand year old
worm Tyrant playing mind games with nuns
and genetic Fanatics you need an average
guy to just stand there and point and
say this is weird
what's going on I don't like this like
you really need something yeah relatable
um
so yeah part of he is curious to you
know like I don't know if they will or
should adapt Jin Messiah but part of me
does want to see Jason Momoa playing a
cyborg philosopher eight
yeah that would uh that would be
fascinating
I love um
the name hate to in Dune Messiah because
it was such such so obviously a jab by
the play laksu it's like they're giving
him Duncan but it's like we also hate
you by the way this is a symbol of hate
we want you to know that yeah it's such
like a school school child no no no
we'll bring back your friend but we're
gonna call him doodoo heads like you
have to keep saying it's like really
guys
yeah
X for the Super Chat from Adam who says
uh what what they could do is show the
wars at first part and as the movie
continues then telling Messiah story or
do what sci-fi did put put both books
into one well yeah I think we talked
about this like you know like the 2000
sci-fi mini-series maybe they could
combine June Messiah and children of
June into one story one adaptation
yeah like do two movies like and have
flashbacks throughout like both maybe or
like yeah I feel like if yeah flashbacks
would be key because I don't think we
could do it where it's like we like
watched the entire Dune Messiah story
like in order and then watch the entire
children of Doom story like in order I
think it would be better handle through
like flashing back and then that way
they can maybe like add a degree of like
mystery to it for people that maybe like
haven't read the books and don't know
what's going on I think flashbacks are
very effective in that way because it
adds an element of like oh what's
happening and and it adds it adds a
degree of like when you get to the end
and you see how everything fits together
it's more satisfying that way yeah yeah
I I agree because I think that there's a
lot of opportunities here to play with
non-linearity and flashbacks and Flash
forwards and Visions because of course
you know the the Dune book has those
quotes at the start of every chapter
which often are telling you what's going
to happen in the book like before UA
betrays later those quotes at the start
of the chapters tell you very early on
that oh yeah yui's gonna betray lato and
Paul's gonna become the Messiah and like
like it spoils the whole thing like
right at the start and and so you know
and that's because the books are about
prescience and the books are about
foresight and the books are about if you
knew what would happen how would that
change your perspective on the world
and so it makes sense for the movies to
to play with that and to change with the
order of things and change our
perspective on things and and in a
really funny meta way
I think that the trailers for this movie
are like prescient visions of the future
like I think that when we see what's
gonna happen at the end of June part two
in the trailers it's almost like we are
Paul seeing the future and our
interpretations of these trailers these
future Visions uh are kind of like how
prescience Works they could be meta with
this if they want
yeah I actually like that interpretation
a lot because it's like we're seeing
like flashes of things that kind of
makes sense but they kind of don't and
they kind of look familiar but they kind
of don't and we're trying to like put it
together and determine like what's
actually going on yeah we we uh Paul try
to interpret these visions and there's
even differences like
uh it's it's tiny but like in the second
trailer this shot of Jessica uh they use
this shot looking at the side of
Jessica's face but in the first trailer
they used a slightly different shot for
this line of Jessica with Jessica facing
the camera and so I mean obviously
that's just minor you know they're still
editing the movie or whatever but but
it's almost like the Visions because we
are seeing alternate possible Futures we
are seeing alternate possible versions
of this movie just like Paul sees
ultimate features and that even goes
back to like the first trailers ever
released because there's so many shots
and lines that like are not actually in
the movie yeah that's interesting even
the CGI is screaming
yeah yeah I think uh in the first
trailer we ever saw like one of the
first ones we see like Paul screaming
when he puts his hand in the box which
never happens we also hear like there's
several lines from the Reverend mother
that never happened um guys Helen
Wilhelm that never happened yeah I just
need that extended version of Doom Denny
yeah give us give us the five hour IMAX
directors Ultra of seven disc Blu-ray
box come on Danny we want it
yeah I I feel like that I have like
copies of the dude dude on Blu-ray at
the Dune Dune on Blu-ray but like
there's not many special features where
are the deleted scenes that's what I
need yeah
yeah it's um
we we always want more but maybe the
Denny is maybe he cut the deleted scenes
for a reason you know like yeah I tend
to think that he knows what he's doing
from what I've heard Danny villanov is
pretty like strong on like no director's
Cuts Like The the movie that I put out
is the movie that's out basically yeah
but I mean also directors have like very
particular Persnickety ideas about what
film is and how their films should be
viewed and that's that's not necessarily
the same way that we view things
um like I I really wish they released
the IMAX aspect ratio version of the
movie on Blu-ray because like there's a
whole half of the movie that you don't
get to see if you don't watch it in IMAX
and some people can't watch it in IMAX
so you know yeah for I feel like some
people don't even realize yeah like so
if you compare like the IMAX version of
like the movie to like the regular
widescreen version it's like there's
there's a whole like several like inches
or something at the top that you don't
see top and bottom that you don't see
yeah
yeah there is there is stuff happening
out of frame that you don't get to see
on the on the Blu-Ray so it's like why
not let people buy that and say that
it's weird
thanks for the Super Chat from Robert
Daniel Picard and from Brendan who says
if water is Earth's oil like water on
arrakis is equivalent to oil on Earth
Frank Herbert said that what Earthling
drug most closely resembles spice
mushrooms or something like Ayahuasca
yeah yeah yeah for sure I mean it's it's
the the direct link to mushrooms is
pretty clear I'm pretty sure like a
friend of Frank Herbert said pretty
conclusively that like Frank Herbert
based the spice trips off of mushrooms
which is very believable it's super
believable I I am kind of like
I I can pull up the actual quotes
um from that because there is that guy
who's like a big uh big fan of mushrooms
who who published this thing saying that
like here are all the ways that uh
psilocybin mushrooms inspired Frank
Herbert
um like he said that it's a particular
species that Frank Herbert was growing
and that it it turns blue wasn't it
golden teacher no maybe not I don't
remember
um but but he also like he made a bunch
of really specific claims like he said
that the maggots that grow around these
mushrooms are what inspired the tune
sand worms and he said that like the
Benny Jesuit were inspired by like
specific kinds of mushrooms psychedelic
Cults in Mexico or something like like
this guy made really specific claims
about how these specific mushrooms
inspired Dune and I I don't know how
true that is like like maybe it's true
and Frank told this to this mushroom guy
or maybe this guy's exaggerating I don't
know but um but yeah like whatever the
degree of it there's obvious Parallels
for sure yeah
um
re-digitized says how are you guys these
days how are you Quinn
I'm doing good uh I just started my new
podcast Cosmic Chronicles podcast you
can check that out if you want I think
the link is in the description yeah
making lots of videos too yeah everyone
go subscribe obviously subscribe to
Quinn's ideas YouTube channel if you
haven't already and also subscribe to
Quinn's new podcast I listen to the
episode about aliens
um oh really that was a fun one yeah I
uh it's um it's a fun topic
mm-hmm
so yeah everyone go subscribe thank you
stank Herbert thank you the fancy
filmmaker who says have you two played
the classic Dune board game
yes I actually have I played it with a
group of friends not too long ago it's a
lot of fun it's a little daunting at
first just looking at it I promise you
if you if you've got like three or four
friends just hope and you guys like
board games totally get it because like
once you get to playing it's it's it's
easy and it's fun and there's it's
there's a lot of strategy involved if
you've ever played something like Risk
um it's kind of similar a little bit so
yeah I recommend it I like is that the
one where they have the um the sort of
slices of arrakis and and the storms
come and sweep across yeah arracus and
Wipeout you dudes yeah like I think
there's a lot of cool that they've
translated the feel of Dean into some
really cool gameplay mechanics it's
really cool yeah
thanks for the Super Chat from Anonymous
who says thanks for this wonderful
Channel love Westworld Bern Arnold oh
man I part of me wants to go back and do
a Westworld season four video because
for some God forsaken reason I did Deep
dive video series into three seasons of
Westworld before it got canceled and
fell apart yeah
um yeah I only ever saw the first season
of Westworld believe it or not I felt
like I was I'd seen enough I'm not hated
on it or anything like that guys I just
I feel like I I don't know does it in
your opinion do like the continuing
Seasons continue to expand the story and
interesting ways
I think he stopped at the right time I I
I really wanted westworld's later
Seasons to be great like I it it it's
Ambitions were so interesting and it was
trying to be something so great and I
was really hopeful that it would achieve
what it was trying to achieve I think
that in many ways it failed like there's
still some things that I like about
Westworld season two and a little bit of
Westworld season three but but
ultimately I don't think it worked in
the later Seasons
um so that's disappointing so yeah I
think you stopped at exactly the right
point
cool it's good to know because I I
definitely I enjoyed the first season
for for what it was I think that because
I've read so many sci-fi books that deal
with similar Concepts I don't think the
first season or just Westville grabbed
me like it grabbed other people but it
was fine yeah it's fine that there was
this stuff about like
um the creators were saying that at this
point we are writing this show for
Reddit they were like oh we love it when
those people on Reddit are trying to
pick apart the theories and make sense
of our timeline and it's like okay like
fine like it's cool that the super nerds
on Reddit and you know old shift X are
having fun picking things apart but do
you really think the average viewer
wants to have to look at a Secret
website to find Clues to figure out what
order these things happening in it's
like that's a bit much it's very David
Lindelof though David Lindelof loves to
do like the viral marketing um David
lindelloff is the guy that did last and
Watchmen he loves to do like the viral
marketing like interactive type of stuff
yeah I I think it's fine to do that but
like don't forget to also tell a story
that is appealing to
average people as well you know you need
to do both you can't just do one or the
other
yeah
have you seen the lesson not everybody's
got time for that have I seen The
Leftovers is that is that the HBO series
it's like a Lindelof thing about the
Rapture I keep having people tell me to
watch it and um I would I would really
like to watch it
I haven't seen it
thanks for the Super Chat from Jordan
who says here to support the Stream
uh do you think that any movie or TV
series will be able to finish the whole
June Saga
what do you reckon do you do you think
that any movie oh oh okay I see what you
mean
um I mean
I don't know the thing with these big
Hollywood movies especially is they
really really need that Capital return
for the movies to continue yeah and
basically if Doom part two doesn't make
like
as much or more than the first movie
we're probably not getting a third big
budget movie
so it just depends on how much it makes
but I feel like a TV show has a has a
much greater chance of succeeding but
even then it's not guaranteed because
like
so many shows get canceled in the in the
first season so many shows that I I
really like like 1899 I thought was
really good canceled in the first season
like the OA I thought was really good
canceled in the second season so I mean
I love the OA season one great show so
sad that it got canceled
um but yeah I I agree that like
um I think a TV series makes more sense
for the later June books like there's
just no way there's going to be a big
budget Hollywood movie about God emperor
of June it's like you can see it as a
three-part mini-series I could see yeah
something like that
yeah and you could honestly do a lot of
the later books lower budget like you'd
have to skimp on some of the battle
scenes but like there aren't many battle
scenes in the later books
um so I I think you could make a more
sort of low budget later books
adaptations similar to the 2000 Sci-Fi
series
I was thinking I don't see why they
didn't just if they were going to do The
Sisterhood of Doom show I think they're
they're trying they were trying to do
some at some loose adaptation of the
Brian Herbert Sisterhood of Dune Bug but
in my opinion I I thought they could
just literally skip to Heretics in
chapter house because I feel like
there's enough time in between that and
the first book where even if you're
watching that show it's not going to
spoil you for the first movie I don't
think because it's about something
fundamentally different and that's just
like the Deep history that's like the
Deep lore
um so I I could have seen them doing
that as a TV show and I thought that
would have been really cool and they
could reference things like the Tyrant
and that just like gives a little bit of
like mystery like like God Emperor
whatever so yeah I could have seen that
yeah I don't know what's going on with
the show now
yeah I I totally agree
um because like as we were saying like
playing with non-linearity makes sense
like have it having a different TV show
that's set 4 000 years after the first
dune movie coming out at the same time
is kind of like wonderfully in keeping
with the themes of prescience in Dune
um and and I agree that like they try
they're trying to make this show about
the benederate which like I think is a
good idea
um there is so much to explore with the
Bene Jesuit and that's why Frank Herbert
wrote two books about them so it's like
what I don't understand is like why
would you try to come up with your own
Benny Jesuit story or why would you
adapt the Brian Herbert prequels and
stuff that a lot of people don't like
why not like Frank has done the hard
work for you already he's done it adapt
adapt Heretics and Chapter House all the
best scenes with Benny jezra are in
Heretics in Chapter House like literally
you see how they function you see like
how the entire organization functions
there's so much information about how
the bidding Jesuit work in those two
books and I've read Sisterhood of Doom
by Brian Herbert and it's about very
very very very early Vinnie Jesuit so
they are not the Masters of the Universe
that we know and love they are not they
don't have the same Powers really yeah
the lore is is off in in other ways as
well and it's just it's just not the
binning Jesuit like I like when they
announced that it was going to be the
Brian book I'm just like okay it's not
like the worst book I've ever read but
they're also not the mini desert
everyone knows and loves so it's just
like why are we even doing this yeah
yeah it's very weird it's a little it's
a little bit like in the Game of Thrones
spin-offs it's it's a bit like if you
made the nymeria's voyage TV show or the
Voyages of Corliss Valeri on TV show
before or you made House of the Dragon
it's like okay like fine like I don't
think it's a terrible idea to make like
an original story about nymeria or
callus or valyria or the Golden Empire
or whatever fine but like why not adapt
the material that we already have first
because it's great and that's what
people love and it's connected and it's
like why yeah it's so weird
and especially because with the Brian
Herbert book is it's called Sisterhood
of Doom but really it's also about the
beginning of the guild and it's other
organizations so actually The Sisterhood
is only a small part it's actually a
part of a Trilogy
um so because they're choosing this they
have to really like make take all these
Liberties and like really expand it you
know so like you said they have to
invent all this extra stuff which like
you already have into big books
so yeah it's weird it sounds like some
of those like um weird old Star Wars
extended Universe stuff where they're
like here's the ancient origins of the
Jedi when they were these dudes on this
planet before lightsabers and before
they understood the force and the Sith
who asked though yeah who like do we
need this like do we need this to be a
TV show is this what we need to spend
millions of dollars on yeah
I
know but we'll see I I I'm pretty sure
Villeneuve pulled out of it from the
last I heard or maybe I'm wrong about
that but I'm pretty sure he pulled out
of it and he's not attached to it
anymore so like I I don't know it's
really up in the air I wish them the
best Yeah Yeah from what I understand
there's a lot of the traditional bad
signs in terms of like the the show
runner exited and some talk about
creative irreconcilable creative
differences and there's a lot of bad
signs about that Ben ages are a TV show
but yeah like you I I hope that it's
great and I'll check it out and let's
see what happens
thanks for the Super Chat from the lady
Eternal who says hi guys I see so much
disrespect for the Sci-Fi adaptations of
Dune out there what are your favorite
parts of those versions who in those
versions gave your favorite performances
okay uh what's her name okay I I
actually like the Sci-Fi versions
um I think they're they're more they're
faithful to the book for the most part I
actually really enjoy Susan Sarandon as
a wins this year and the children of
doing one I think she does a really cool
job
um
I'm not crazy about the guy that plays
Paul
um
let's see I think the baron is okay the
baron is okay I feel like he's he's he's
closer to the the actual Baron than what
we see in the David Lynch Dune
um as far as favorite
parts
oh I'm freaking I'm totally blanking on
them what's his name what's his name the
guy from X-Men what's his name the guy
that plays Leto the second yeah
he's great
um but he's a little old he's a little
old
um but yeah
I I enjoy all the people making fun of
the 2000 series for uh all of the hats
there are some the spectrums are
terrible spectacularly enormous hats
like I mean check out check out this hat
on guys
like every second character has hats
it's ridiculous and also um The Guild
hats are so ridiculous and there's
there's some really weird lying
deliveries in the in the mini series as
well yeah right with there's that one
famous clip that went viral a while ago
with the guild Navigator like the guild
does not take your artists and it's
literally that dramatic it's like a wet
guy I like like I kind of enjoy that
specifically with the guild guys because
the guild uh space weirdos who no one
likes like they are like these barely
human yeah like like these hats and I
think this this moment with this voice
and Guild is hilarious and they're so
weird they look ridiculous I I kind of
dig it
um
but I don't know I feel like I don't
know if it's like the pacing or the
writing but I I find the 2000 series
hard to watch like I I find it not super
compelling like on paper like yes it is
a more faithful adaptation of the book
than the Lynch movie
um it includes more of the book stuff
than the villanov movies include like on
on paper it's it's good but I I don't I
don't I don't it doesn't grab me as much
I'm not sure why
I totally get it I feel like it comes
from like an era that's like very
nostalgic for me because I watched a lot
of sci-fi Channel Growing Up and it just
looks and sounds like things that I saw
when I was a kid so what I first saw it
I think it was very comforting for me
even though I did see that as an adult
it was very nostalgic to watch even
though I've never seen it before so I'm
coming at it from that angle too
um and then also too because the time of
this mini series it's like a it heralded
like a shift to change in the
in the way sci-fi was doing things they
went from like doing like adaptations of
things and more like sci-fi things to
doing like more silly things this is and
doing more reality show type things so
this is like the end of that era yeah so
it's it's interesting I also find that
it's definitely flawed
I also find the bad CGI to be quite
Charming like you can sort of tell that
this this kind of CGI technology was
kind of new and exciting and it's like
oh we can make CGI cities and planets
and wow isn't this amazing and it's like
yeah it looks quite bad in retrospect
but I'm still very fond of it because
they were obviously having fun with it
yeah
it's definitely not pretty it's
definitely ugly definitely ugly but it's
like it's like Earnest you know I I like
how they did The fremin Siege and the
glow Globes and stuff like that they had
a limited budget and they did a pretty
pretty good effort you know I think so
yeah there's things that I like about it
and interestingly part of it is that um
they have this ear alarm plot line in
the 2000 Series where euroland is
investigating Paula trades and she's
hanging out with fade and she's
um she's she's a much more active
character than she is in the book and it
it seems like they're doing something
very similar in the uh movie it seems
like they're drawing inspiration which
is interesting
yeah
see the thing about the Dune mini series
2 is that it's a mini series and it's
very like it's long how long is the
first one I think the first one is like
five hours at least and then the second
one is also like another five hours yeah
so it's like a lot to get through it's a
lot to get through it's very spaced out
there are some additional scenes and
added moments so it's very the pacing
isn't great I will say that the pacing
is definitely not great
yeah yeah it does not feel like a show
that has
edited down to its most essential Parts
it it feels like it's luxuriating in its
in its run time
at the same time I'm also like really
happy that this came out at a time where
it could get made because it might it
this might well be the only adaptation
of Dune and children of Doom that we
ever get yeah so for even all of its
flaws
it's cool and also I think if you just
look at it like okay this is a play that
I'm watching if you don't think about it
like this is a this is a a mini
series that's been filmed then I feel
like it works a little bit better
because it look it's like the way it's
it looks like a play it looks like
something it looks like they're out of
stage yeah yeah I agree like I feel like
it's like healthy to alter our
expectations and go you know like not
everything has to be photo realistic and
and not everything has to be like
beautifully framed and cinematic like
the real nerve stuff is like sometimes
we can just watch your story being
played out by some actors and that can
be great and fun you know like and also
like low budget like we need more low
budget stuff like we need not everything
needs to be a Disney Mega Million Dollar
thing like when when we change our
expectations we can see more new kinds
of stories so you know yeah I agree I'm
glad that the 2000 adaptation exists
yeah oh well to since we mentioned the
podcast my new podcast Cosmic Chronicles
go subscribe to it our new episode Link
in the description our new episode is
about some of our like favorite
independent small Sci-Fi movies yeah and
these are the type of movies that get
overlooked but they're and usually
they're better than like I don't know
like a 200 million dollar like Tom
Cruise movie or something like that so I
I am all for simple low budget sci-fi
flicks I'm a big fan of Star Trek the
Next Generation yeah
um and some of those episodes It's just
them on that ship talking in a room and
that's the entire the entire episode and
it's some of the best television you
will ever watch so I'm I love low budget
stuff and I'm down for and I wish there
was more of it
yeah I think um George Martin uh talked
a lot about I Claudius which is this old
70s Show
um about Roman history and the Roman
emperors and
um that was something that he compared
to House of the dragon and he talked
about how I Claudius was super old
budget low budget and it all happened in
like one tiny room and one set and there
are these Roman columns behind the
actors and sometimes the Roman columns
uh flap in the breeze when they walk
past them because they're just these
like sheets with like columns painted on
them and so it's super low budget but
like yeah you look at it more as theater
and you can still appreciate it and um
yeah and yeah like I'm conscious that
Ultra attacks they're all these old
shift x videos about these you know High
budget HBO TV shows and stuff which is
like cool and fine but like I I think
it's I'm also really happy to do stuff
like all tomorrows which is about a
obscure
Turkish science fiction story by the
wonderful and inimitable CM kosaman who
everyone should also subscribe to on
YouTube
um I I think that you know as people
with YouTube channels it's good for us
to have a look at a wide variety and
diversity of stories not just whatever's
coming out of Hollywood
I definitely agree that's kind of been
my mission for a little bit kind of but
yeah I have I actually also since you
brought up all tomorrow so I haven't
read that
but I've had like so many people ask me
to cover it since you did that video and
I'm just like no I'll chip decks did a
great video on it watches
yeah it's interesting yeah yeah thanks
yeah I think it's like I also got
requests for like make more altamara's
stuff but it's like it I I it it's been
cool to see like other people take that
up and make all the ultimara stuff and
people check out more of CM kosman's
work like to use it as to use it as like
a starting point to look at more other
stuff and create more other stuff and
um yeah no I'm all for that
it no yeah it it we don't need like 10
more all tomorrow sequels you know like
CM kosman could have done well here's
all tomorrow's two and three and four
and but but he is someone who wants to
explore new stuff and
um not just repeat the same thing so
that's the other thing like like we
don't need like constant sequels all the
time you know like when you when you get
excited about a story Your Instinct
shouldn't be how do how do I make 10
more of the same thing the Instinct
should be
how do I iterate on this and how do I
alter this and that's what Frank
Herbert's about right every June book is
radically different to the first one
every June book takes a radically
different perspective and that's Frank's
entire Point don't just do the same
thing over and over keep Reinventing
yourself
yeah I really agree with you on the SQL
Point like how many times do you
encounter like a series where the first
thing is good and then there's just like
five just like god-awful sequels it
happens so often because something is
popular and then they like want to just
repeat the same thing over and over
again and everything else it's just like
a pale shadow of what came before yeah
yeah
um thank you for the Super Chat from mon
Berry and from Bert and from mon Berry
who says you were the first person with
a soothing voice to sleep and yet still
be conscious enough to listen to It's
hard to explain sorry some might
understand a whole shift x
uh I'm glad I'm glad you enjoyed one
Perry thank you Mitch Evans thank you
Eric who says if Paul turns away are we
left to assume Humanity would become
extinct was there no other path or way
would the big quizets how to Rack qh
lead to destruction qh what is qh mean
maybe I think they meant to say quiz
that's had Iraq maybe yeah with the
Benny Jesuit
I don't know yeah um so so if Paul if
Paul just just noped out do you think
that Humanity would have gone extinct
at what point are we talking
um
at what point knocked out we're talking
like in in in in Doom the first book
yeah because I feel like if if Paul that
died in the first book the Benny dresser
it would have just tried again to make
another quiz of tetarak yeah
yeah I mean there is like like at the
end of June or like at several points in
June Paul is like if I die now the Jihad
will happen anyway with or without me
um oh yeah once he goes past a certain
point it's it's immovable then he he he
would just be the figure out he would be
like a martyr literally
yeah I agree and like if you know if the
Atreides never went to Iraqis or
anything like like I agree like the
Benny jazzer it would just keep on
plotting and they would eventually
probably produce a quiz outside Iraq
um so so that's the funny thing like
despite all Paul's efforts he kind of
changes nothing I mean I guess he makes
the you know the Forman Uprising and the
Jihad and stuff happen but but I mean if
you look at God emperor in later the
second it's like you know his concerns
about the about the extinction of
humanity that would have been an issue
regardless of whether more Deep's Empire
happened or not
yeah like okay so Paul doesn't see
the thing with the great enemy until
like at some point after dude Messiah
because he's he there's a scene where
he's thinking like oh the concerns I had
before like what I'm seeing now is way
worse way worse
um so that's related to the great enemy
somehow in
All That Jazz with the potential like
ixian machines and the the face dancers
and all that stuff yeah when when stuff
gets real confusing in the later books
yeah
uh thank you Mack Brown for the Super
Chat who says favorite Dune character
favorite Doom character
oh this is kind of I guess I I have to
say later II I just think he's so
intriguing and weird and cool and just
bizarre and just like everything about
that character is so interesting and I
could read another book of his ramblings
honestly
I love how much of book four is just
that it's just later traveling
complaining about these feelings and
about politics and one of the really
like fun realizations I had about Dune
um is that uh Frank Herbert the author
of June reportedly had a lot of trouble
with the IRS who were hounding him to
pay his taxes for a lot of the last
years of his life which really
um gives new context to some of lato's
rants about the government and
bureaucracy oh yeah like a lot of June
is about like you know I really hate
having to comply with governments and
governments are always crap and you know
yeah why should we have to follow these
rules and then you read on Wikipedia
that Frank Herbert was was not paying
his taxes for the teen books that's like
oh yeah he and like there's all this
interesting like you know like Frank
Herbert was a speechwriter for
Republican politicians in America for a
while and like like you know whatever
you assume about the politics of June
it's more complicated than that is is
what I'll say yeah
I will say that I think that Frank
Herbert takes a part of that disdain
from bureaucracy for bureaucracy from
Asimov with Foundation because
um Foundation I mean Asimov frames
bureaucracy as one of the reasons that
the empire fell like the main reason
actually was like the fact that like the
bureaucracy on Tran tour couldn't really
handle the needs of like the entire
universe so it just kind of collapsed
upon itself
so I always thought maybe he took a
little bit of that element from that but
I didn't know the taxes thing so maybe
that definitely probably contributed
contributes to it as well yeah yeah I I
don't know how true some of those uh
allegations are but um it it kind of
makes a lot of sense like like you know
like it's really fun to get into the
Sci-Fi World building imagination of it
all but like Dune is also very obviously
just like this smart old American guy
complaining about the government like
old man yeah old man shakes old man
shouts at cloud like that is a lot of
the energy of especially the later books
to me yeah
um in terms of like favorite Gene
characters I mean someone who I'd love
to talk about is uh count hasimir
fenring
and I I'm the failed quiz attack the
failed quiz at sad Iraq do you want to
explain who he is
so the Benny Jesuit have been trying to
make the quiz of cataract for a very
long time and they've been they've
tested people before and usually they
die and Finn ring was one that didn't
come quite come out right he's he was
almost a quiz of cataract but no
I think that's a deal with fendering
yeah
um and he's invisible to Paul's
prescience these visions of the future
and so it's this wonderful moment in the
final chapter of Dune when Paul sees
Hashmi offendering I mean like he sees
fade and he's like oh yeah I had visions
of Faith that's fine he sees the emperor
he's like yeah I know what's going on
with the emperor I know what's going on
with the spacing Guild that's all fine
but then he locks eyes with count has to
be offendering and he's like
who is this guy continue oh my God
and then he realizes
yeah
I was just gonna say that's a concept
that we continue to explore in doing
Messiah the fact that people can be
hidden from prescience so you know yeah
I think it's meant to be this this like
Frank talks about Heisenberg uncertainty
or whatever and it's like it's like you
know when you observe
When You observe you alter reality and
it's this idea of you know if you can
see the future but they can see the
future if you alter something you alter
what they can alter it into this weird
sort of uh mind that means that
people who can see the future uh disrupt
each other's ability to see the future
which makes a lot of sense to me
yeah yeah I don't know if I'm smart
enough to fully get the physics of it
but I think that it's a little esoteric
it def it definitely makes life it makes
intuitive sense that like if you could
see the future and someone else can see
the future you could alternate alter it
in a way that disrupts their vision and
so yeah that's a huge plot Point later
on but um but but fenring like I I
another sort of matter irony of
phenering is that the guy who Paul can't
see in his visions of the future
hassamia does not appear in the Dune
trailers so far the guy who Paul
couldn't foresee we can't foresee
Margo we see Margo
we don't see hassania that was a good
point I didn't even think about it that
way but that goes back to your like idea
or your concept of the trailers acting
like a form of prescience That's So Meta
if that's actually what they're going
for right I don't know if it's
deliberate but it kind of perfectly fits
um there is some question though as to
whether
hassamia will be in the movie at all
like there's been reports that uh Tim
Blake Nelson
will be in Dune and some people have
speculated that he may play hassamia and
I think that may make sense Tim Blake
Nelson said on a podcast that his role
in June part 2 is a quote Cameo so it's
not a it's not a large role
um which which fits with the book like
hasmia literally only appears in one
scene in the book so so they could still
be well no sorry he also appears with
Margot on gaily Prime so so you know are
they gonna Faithfully do hassamia I
don't know I hope they do
but I could also see this being one of
the things that
they might cut yeah because it is kind
of just like a oh and this you know it's
kind of uh yeah I don't know it's not as
crucial to that first book
as some other things
yeah it's like if you're if you're
choosing what to include and what not to
include in a junior adaptation hassami
is a very obvious well he's not
completely essential
um like I love it I I love I love it
because it I love it because it expands
our perspective like I think part of the
point of hassamia is like Paul thinks he
knows everything and has to be proves
that he does not like there exists there
exists more in heaven and earth like
there are there are forces beyond your
understanding and I and I think that
that also connects to
uh the idea of who's the best fighter in
the world because uh you know we like
Paul's teachers Gurney and Duncan are
meant to be like literally some of the
best fighters in the world and and Paul
seems to be one of the best in the world
and so it's like they they are the best
there is but then they say hassamia and
it says several times that hassamia is a
better fighter than Paul and could kill
Paul he just chooses not to and so it's
this sort of humbling moment where where
Paul thinks that he and his friends are
the best smartest most powerful toughest
dudes in the universe but hassami is
like no you are not there there are
other forces that you don't understand
there are other people with other
emotional you know internal worlds that
that you do not fully comprehend and so
I think it's this humbling moment that's
really beautiful
it's kind of like we've witnessed Paul
become like all powerful and then it's
like actually
no yeah so yeah yeah which is the rug
pull that Frank does a million times you
think you're the all-powerful hero no no
it's more complicated but I could almost
I could almost see that being almost
confusing in the movie if not done
correctly yeah you know what I mean yeah
so I could understand why they would
choose to keep Finn ring out and I'm not
like super pissed off if he's not in the
movie I'll just say that
yeah yeah it's another one of those
things that is subversive about the book
that they might not want to include in a
Hollywood movie I think it would be cool
if they did but yeah maybe they won't
um so we're hoping that hassamia will be
in the movie we we think that Alia will
be in the movie what about through fear
what are they gonna do with the fear in
June part two who fear Howard
um I could see I I feel like it'll it'll
be a small role I don't I wonder if
they're going to include the whole plot
line
with the poisoning I don't know I mean I
feel like we've got to see the baron
doing some evil things to a character
yeah you know what I mean
so I feel like I feel like I think I
think they'll keep this role relatively
similar it's not like that significant
in the book anyway he's just like kind
of like
hanging out with the baron
so you don't think they're gonna have
through fear milk a cash to get his
antidote like they did in the let's not
forget the milk the cat you know no I
don't think so I don't understand the
cat milky thing that's that see that's
David Lynch being weird for the sake of
being weird he loves that we love it
minus the cat milk
yeah I um I I think that the sufier plot
line in the second half of June is very
weird and confusing like it's such an
elaborate storyline where it's like like
sufia plotted with Fade to have an
undrugged slave in the Gladiator for
fate to fight for the purpose of
discrediting Vladimir's slave master so
that fade can replace the slave master
with a different slave master which
ultimately doesn't work because when
Faye tries to assassinate Vladimir
Vladimir has the slave the new slave
master killed so that sort of goes
nowhere but then through fear warned
Vladimir about Fades assassination
attempt on Vladimir so thufir is working
for both Vladimir and fade against each
other
has the poison and he dies at the end so
like he like it seems like through fear
is partying against the Harkins but he
doesn't manage to actually accomplish
anything against the Harkins and he dies
and it's and it's like it's a little
convoluted it's very convoluted and
confusing and goes nowhere so it's like
what what exactly does it need to be in
the movie I don't know
I don't know I feel for some reason I
feel like they're gonna keep the
poisoning aspect of it because that's
kind of cool you know like the poison
and the antidote or whatever but
I don't know I don't see them just like
killing him off so I feel like they've
got to give them something that
something to do right I don't know if
they're gonna keep I don't think they're
gonna do it
I don't know I don't know it's gonna be
like it could go
I don't know if it necessarily makes
that much sense for a movie subplot yeah
to have it be so convoluted and complex
when in a movie that's already complex
and when we need to be spending time
like explaining other things that matter
more to the narrative so I could see
them cutting or altering a lot of it
yeah yeah like hassamia I I think
thufius plot is is a logical thing to uh
not include fully in the movie but like
I'm trying to imagine what they will do
because like you know Sufi is a
character in this movie he's got a
something's got to happen to him so
presumably it'll be being poisoned like
in the book but like if the the only
thing that would be weirder than
actually including the weird book
plotline would be not including all the
plots and just having through fear turn
up in the final scene and say hey Paul
haven't seen you for a while oh no I've
been poisoned and now I'm dead like
can you imagine how bizarre that would
be if you just turns up and dies without
the context like that's even weirder
right yeah
yeah so I maybe he dies before but I I
don't know I don't know if they're gonna
miss out on the chance of giving him
that reconnection with Paul
so it's just I don't know I don't know
how they're gonna do it because if he
doesn't die before that
then he's gonna be in the ending scene
and maybe be poisoned and die but then
if he dies before that then like he
doesn't get like the final moment and
the resolution with Paula Charities so
it's just like I don't know something
needs to be changed or altered yeah I
agree it's really puzzling
um and and you know of course that's one
of the things about the book ending that
is just
um just just sort of weird and hilarious
and awkward that there's there's just
this succession like like Paul basically
holds a meeting in the Final Chapter and
he's like together everyone form an
orderly cue and I will decide the fates
of everybody at the end because I'm the
emperor now and so he says well Emperor
I'm I'm exiling you and irelan I'm
marrying you and fate I'm killing you
and fear you're dead that's sad like you
just sort of it's like this ridiculous
conveyor belt of character resolutions
that we get and um yeah I think it would
feel even more weird and awkward and has
to me it would feel even more weird if
they did that Faithfully
yeah and the way it happens in the book
is pretty sudden too which is like it
comes to the next scene and like
everyone's here hi guys yeah
and and with regard to that whole you
know the G80 Prime through fear hassamia
Margo plotline I I'm really curious to
see what they do with Margot phenering
how do you feel about Margo
I don't know I feel like she's our um
she's our Gateway into like the Benny
Jesuit and when the way they're
operating I think I think we'll see
Benny Jesuit motives through Margo
fittering I think that's what they're
going for here because the bitty Jets
were very like
I feel I feel like she's our only only
opportunity to see the Benny Jesuit and
the way they operate in this movie you
know what I mean because we're not going
to be seeing much of guys hell in Ohio
we're not going to be seeing the Benny
Jesuit chapter house or anything like
that so we need to see a Benny Jesuit
that's not Jessica
and the way she operates so I think
that's the purpose more or less of
Margot in this movie
yeah yeah I agree because like like
Jessica is not a great window onto the
Benny Jesuit because she's a rogue Benny
Jesuit and she's going totally off their
plans whereas Margot seems to be someone
who is loyal to the like Orthodox Penny
Jesuit and their plans so I wonder if
they might be able to sneak in a little
bit of explanation about like what the
benedjesar breeding plan is and what the
quiz outside Iraq is because like a lot
of casual viewers of the movies would
not know what is going on with that so
yeah maybe she is our window into that
she's very pretty she's very she looks
she looks like a Benny Jesuit I think
yeah
um Leia's she's a very interesting look
yeah yeah I like it
um there's something that I that took me
a while to understand about the Margot
fade thing is that like you know in the
book she she goes to Getty Prime
basically to have sex with fade and to
get pregnant from fade so the the
bandage Ezra can like uh
keep and protect Fade's DNA because he
he's from the breeding program he has
these special genes he you know that
genetic material is useful for producing
the quiz outside Iraq but but something
something that took me a while to
understand is that like in the last
chapter before Paul fights fade Jessica
says hey Paul there's this trigger word
this hypnotic implanted trigger word
that the Bene Jesuit put in people
sometimes in case we ever have to kill
them and this word is
and if you say you rational to fade he
will be weakened so you can kill him
easier
and Paul says I'm not going to do that
I'm going to do a fair fight I'm gonna
say it
but it took me a while to realize that
that Margot must have implanted that
trigger word in fade when they hooked up
it makes perfect sense
yeah and it's something that is it's
never explained in the book but it it
just sort of makes sense that that
happened then
um I don't think I've ever thought about
that but that makes the most sense yeah
right
um so that's that's something that they
could do in the movie because they do
seem to be showing us fade and Margo's
encounter in this movie in a way that we
we don't see in the book
and it would help illustrate the Benny
Jesuit Powers yeah a little bit more if
we if we show something like that
yeah we show the strength of their
conditioning show the strength of what
they can like do to a person's mind if
you let them in
yeah yeah agreed because yeah like we've
seen Jessica beat up stilgar and like
you the benefits can fight but like you
know the point is that the bandages have
powers that are better than violence and
and that is emotional psychological
linguistic perceptual religious like
they have so much more than just
punching people so yeah I hope Mario
shows us that
um we got to see Siege to beer
in the trailers which I thought was
really cool there's like this vast shot
where we get to see the the crowds the
like thousands and thousands of fremin
in this massive crowd
um which I thought was extremely cool
there's also this weird shot of of it
what it's what it looks like Paul
walking
forwards with like a sand worm exploding
out of the ground behind him I think
yeah
so that's interesting because Paul can't
necessarily control sand worms in the
way that you know someone like later II
or even later like Shiana could yeah so
I I I don't I don't really know what to
make of that perhaps it's a vision or
perhaps we're seeing I don't know
because even if he was about to mount
the sand worm to charge into attack he
wouldn't be standing directly in front
of it it doesn't like practically make
sense so yeah I I maybe it's a vision
someone's saying that it doesn't look
like Paul maybe it's Aaliyah I don't
know
it's not sure it seems to be a moment of
like total confidence like it's a cool
guys don't look at explosions moment
um so this is not Paul's first encounter
with a sand worm like I wonder if this
is like Paul summoning the sand worms
for the final attack on the emperor at
the end
which
is you know a kind of a logical thing
for them to do but it's it's not
something that's in the book
um it's interesting so it makes sense on
a certain level
it makes sense to a certain degree
but then again it makes more sense for
later because you know the the sand
trout skin and the fact that he actually
is Freeman Genetically speaking so I
don't know I guess we'll just have to
see it might just be like an interesting
stylistic visual choice that they've
made in the moment
yeah it I mean it certainly looks cool
for the trailer
yeah
speaking of sand trout I thought this
costume that erilan is in
um is pretty interesting because just
visually with the little sort of blobs
all over her body or sectional pieces
surrounding her face yeah it um it kind
of resembles later on the soundtrack
don't you think
the way it's described in the book for
sure because he talks about how it's
just like his face that you can see like
he didn't let it like cover his face and
like that's all that's like really left
by the end so yeah it does kind of it it
is a little bit reminiscent of that
um yeah that looks cool and again it
almost looks like armor and it's similar
to this other costume I was thinking
with like the chain mail
do you think you're almost like
probably not and in fact I think I can I
can compare it to um
almost like Cersei right like in Game of
Thrones the show the way they do her
dresses is they're like using armor to
make it look more like I don't know
I don't even know what the word is but
it kind of reminds me of that it's not
this is way more like extreme like
Cersei didn't do like the headpieces and
stuff like that but it kind of made me
think of that a little bit
yeah yeah I think that's a good I don't
see Iran as a fighter like erlon is a
scholar I don't I don't see her as a
fighter yeah yeah right yeah like like
she she's the person who writes the the
books about Paul and she's got literary
pretensions or whatever the term is in
the book so yeah it is weird seeing her
as this armored badass is what she looks
like
and it's so weird seeing like I'm still
not sure if like this figure on the
right here in this shot approaching I
guess this is the captive shishakly and
you know is this eralon facing shishakly
is eralon on arrakis with soldiers like
trying to find Paul
that'd be different yeah that'd be a
huge change the background in erlon
doesn't look like it's in a rock cave
though
yeah it's called the metallic
it's like horizontal lights
maybe that would not be in this cave the
editing is um
yeah it's ambiguous
yeah
it's interesting hmm
but I know with trailers they do weave
together shots to make it sometimes look
like certain things are happening when
they're not yeah yeah they can
definitely be missed later
thanks for the Super Chat from Trent who
says that the Dune 2000 uh real-time
strategy game introduced house ordos
very underrated game uh the cutscenes
were very campy like the series
have you played that game
I never played it unfortunately a lot of
people people have been recommending it
to me for years but I have not played it
yeah I think I've seen some clips from
the from the cutscenes they do look uh
very hilarious and fun and cool
um yeah be cool to check it out but uh I
imagine that game may have may have
dated poorly
after all these years
yeah I was never a fan of games like
that I mean I played SimCity
but like they're really like yeah the
really in-depth like strategy games like
were over my head not a big Starcraft
guy
no God no I couldn't do Starcraft thanks
also for uh cryos 23s Super Chat
um I feel like we should wrap this
stream up shortly we've been talking for
two hours
um
but there's one thing I would like to
discuss which is um amidst all the you
know the highbrow philosophy of tune all
the all the clever deep questions that
it asks I think there's one question
that is uh completely ridiculous and and
dumb but I I want to think about any I
want to think about it anyway which is
who is the best fighter in June who is
the strongest Warrior who could beat
anyone else who do you think is the
greatest warrior in June
thought you were gonna say what are
chair dogs
what does what does sleeks do the
biggest so in the first book or are we
talking the whole Saga yeah I I yeah I
feel like those are two distinct
questions who is the greatest fighter in
the first June book and secondarily who
is the best fighter in the entire series
First Student Book Duncan Idaho
I would say that Duncan Idaho would
probably come out ahead if he really
really wanted to I feel like Paul would
give him a good fight but I think Duncan
Idaho might might take it out
and as far as like the whole Dune series
best fighter
best fighter like hand-to-hand combat
it's got to be Marbella or I guess maybe
miles tag once he gets that crazy
superpower but like other than that
Marbella probably
yeah yeah I mean mabella's got to be one
of the most skilled combatants because
like we we see that towards the end and
we and and like philosophically like she
is the combination of uh honored
matrey's powers and wisdom combined with
benejera training and restraint and it's
like like logically that's like the
combination of of the best ideas and the
best Minds makes you the best fighter
that's kind of the philosophy of
fighting in June it's all about the mind
so so like I think mabella makes sense
but yeah as you say like miles Tech
becomes the flash you know yeah like
there's that bit where like miles tag
just runs into
um a honored mattress place and he just
turns all the honored matres into Red
Mist because
so much faster like they don't have the
speed force and he does so like I tend
to think that
tag with his speed powers could beat
mabella even if mabella is like you know
theoretically the most like highly
trained fighter
agreed
so what about for the first Dune Bug and
your opinion
well I see I I want to say Duncan but
there is a bit in uh the later books
where Gurney says or Duncan says that
Gurney was a better fighter than him
Gurney can be Duncan six times out of
ten
so
I I think that textually Gurney is meant
to be a better fighter I mean of course
the later Gola resurrections of Duncan
he gets upgraded he gets upgraded so you
know Duncan is on a a higher tier in the
later books but like for the first book
Gurney is meant to be better than Duncan
Mike my question in the first book
though is like is Paul
and hasamiya better than Gurney because
we are told that hashemy is better than
Paul
um but is Paul and hasmia better than
Gurney because like it's funny because
like like some of the later books
suggest that Paul really was one of the
best fighters ever but like the actual
people who pull fights are jamus who's
just like this average fremin guy and
fade who is this treacherous talking and
but like fate is not a top tier fighter
as far as anyone's he's been cheating
anyway yeah and he mostly fights like
slaves that have been drunk so they're
easy to kill
yeah so we never see Paul fight someone
who's really meant to be a top tier
fighter so it's really hard to know if
Paul is better or worse than Gurney
true
definitely true
yeah but because I you can I guess you
can
um by the end of the book it's pretty
clear that Paul has improved as a
fighter but you never you can't really
know like how much yeah in comparison to
somebody like Gurney who's also been
like out here in the trenches fighting
the entire time and no doubt like
improving his skills too so yeah yeah
and I mean Gurney's weird as well
because Gurney
um we are told is one of the best
fighters in the universe but we don't
see him fight anyone except for like
book three when he kills like Javed or
someone he kills some fremin guy but
he's not a particularly strong fighter
as far as we know so it's like so it's
really funny that like there's all these
top and like hasimir as well is
Apparently one of the best ever but we
never see him fight anyone
yeah it's interesting and I feel like I
feel Danny Villeneuve has got to give us
that that big Gurney moment you got to
give Gurney his Moment Like dunking God
is like awesome oh man we gotta give it
to Gurney too
yeah yeah I thought some of Goonies like
fight scenes in the first movie were
like a bit underwhelming like he sort of
like kills a couple of Hawking and red
shirts we don't sing much yeah we really
don't see much I I mean the training
scene with Paul was pretty cool but yeah
I hope we get more
yeah
one of the things I would have loved to
see I I think I mentioned this before in
one of my streams or something I would
have loved to see in the first movie uh
the trades soldiers get trapped in the
cave because I feel like that's a really
like yeah devastating thing that happens
that like it shows you how cruel the
hakonans really are it was a devastating
moment and it should I don't know it
just highlights their cruelty yeah for
sure and it also has like an interesting
sort of technological story to it like
it's a fun idea that like the Hawkings
are bringing back this like ancient
technology of like this ballistic
um artillery and it's it's a surprise
it's like bringing a blunderbuss to a
modern conflict or something like what
are you doing yeah
and it fits this whole idea yeah it's
all about surprises and tricks and and
mind games and so you know I I I can
imagine it almost as like I mean I don't
think they'll do it but it could be a
cool opening scene to June part two to
like have the Atreides soldiers you know
trapped in the caves and going oh these
Hawkins have taken over the planet oh
how are we gonna Escape you know and
then just getting caved by by these
um artillery strikes and then the baron
you know gloating uh from afar I think
all of that could be fun to say
yeah
brutal
um all right I I guess we better wrap up
this stream are there any sort of last
thoughts you have about June that you
want to say anything else you're looking
forward to
I'm just looking forward to seeing the
movie when it comes out and I'm very
excited about it and I hope it doesn't
get postponed to 2024 like some of the
rumors we're saying because I think that
the time they have set is the best time
to do it yeah people are hyped about it
you've already released two trailers and
I think it would be a bad idea to
postpone it I'm just excited to see it
and the way it ends and I'm excited to
see all the performances and hopefully a
guild Navigator
so yeah yeah it's been a lot of fun
having this chat anytime yeah yeah no
this was great thank you for for coming
on and
um I hope we can chat again after the
new movie comes out
totally sounds like fun thanks everybody
for watching and listening yeah and uh
go and subscribe to Quinn's ideas on
YouTube if you haven't already Link in
the description and also check out
Quinn's new podcast
Cosmic Chronicles
love it all right thank you so much
Quinn
foreign
that was fun uh we're gonna wrap this up
uh I'll respond to this super chat from
Bert who says have you watched
invincible
series is great but the comics are
incredible yeah no I haven't seen or
read Invincible I've heard good things
um
also uh what's that other superhero
Thing the boys that was another I think
uh similar-ish show sort of gritty dark
superhero thing that people keep telling
me to watch I watch like I watched like
the first season of the boys and kind of
enjoyed it left through the comic seemed
kind of cool but um yeah I don't know I
I feel like Watchmen is like as much
gritty superhero stuff as I need
um so uh yeah I haven't checked out much
other superhero stuff since
uh and thank you for the Super Chat from
Jordan who says love your Swift well you
know I'll shift X isn't here I'm alt
shift X
uh you know I don't know what that Swift
person is all about but uh but I'll pass
on your kind words
pretty much for everybody uh we are now
working on a big video about Jon Snow
the real Jon Snow uh looking forward to
finishing that uh we will also do more
um
Dune stuff later on philosophy of June
the real June part two looking forward
to doing that stuff uh House of the
Dragon we're gonna cover when the second
season comes out might also do some more
House of the Dragon stuff before then
so yeah more song of us in fire more hot
day more Dune more other stuff looking
forward to it uh please press like And
subscribe if you haven't if you'd like
to support alt shift X you can sign up
to the patreon patrons get videos early
usually like 24 hours before the public
release uh there's also a monthly live
stream for live stream tier patrons
which is like uh an hour of chatting
about the videos that are in production
and uh it's a great way to support old
shift X and I really appreciate all the
patronage
uh check out Quinn's Channel and Quinn's
podcast there's also an ALT shift X
podcast there's actually two alt shift X
podcast feeds one with uh podcast uh
chats and live streams and one with the
main alt shift x videos as audio so you
can listen to all the alt shift X stuff
on Spotify or podcast apps if you'd like
links are in the description
but uh yeah thank you for the support
and we will do more cool stuff soon
thanks guys